Saw war ein wirklich Bemerkenswerter
Sturm eigentlich nicht besonders groß waren seine Folgen doch immens der Bahnverkehr in Norddeutschland wurde komplett eingestellt
Mindestens sieben Toten bis zu 61 Liter regen Pro quadratmeter Windgeschwindigkeiten von 180 Kilometern Pro Stunde
Und so weiter und so fort das Bild hier, das habe ich gestern auf Instagram gepostet
Das ist schon absolut irre so war auch kein Normaler Sturm, sondern ein Schnellläufer
Was das ist und warum die Ausführung so dramatisch sind und was das ganze mit dem Klimawandel zu tun?
Hat jetzt den Krieg zum Science Fiction herzlich willkommen?
Wow was für ein Bild so sah es gestern auf dem Kudamm in Berlin aus nichts ging mehr in der Bundeshauptstadt auf dem Kurfürstendamm
Vor kein Bus mehr der S
Bahn Betrieb war komplett eingestellt worden und Bundesweit war es absolut verheerend kein Zug Fuhr mehr in Bremen Hamburg Schleswig-Holstein Niedersachsen
Brandenburg
Mecklenburg-Vorpommern und natürlich auch in Berlin im gesamten Norden der Republik und das ist auch am Tag danach
Noch immer dramatisch da laufen im Moment noch die Reparaturen auf vielen strecken geht eben immer noch nichts Fährverbindungen wurden eingestellt
Stromausfälle und Es gab sieben Tote meistens übrigens durch umstürzende Bäume, also besser drinnen bleiben bei solch heftigen Stürmen
Aber was war an so ungewöhnlich, warum hat ein so kleiner Sturm so krasse Auswirkungen, die Antwort ist ganz einfach aber
erklärungsbedürftig ist ein Schnellläufer nach seiner Entstehung in der Nacht zum Mittwoch im
Südwesten Island Zucker mit einem tatsächlichen Affenzahn nach Deutschland Möglich macht das der
Jetstream Rund um die Arktis in einer Höhe von Rund zehn Kilometern zieht er mit Rund
200 bis 500 Kilometern Pro Stunde Rund um die Arktis und beeinflusst unser Wetter maßgeblich
Er schiebt hoch und Tiefdruckgebiete hin und her und je nachdem wie ihr verläuft kann er auch mal ein Tiefdruckgebiet mit hoher Geschwindigkeit
In den Süden kicken ja
Das muss man schon sagen in diesem Fall das übrigens auch eine Folge des Klimawandels der Jackson
Der wart immer mehr nach Süden eine Folge der immer wärmeren Arktis die den Polaren Jetstream
Schwächt der fängt dadurch an im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes Herum zu Eiern
Es bilden sich beulen im Stream die sogenannten Roski wellen sie bringen
Paradoxerweise jetzt auch kalte Polarluft mit viel schnee weiter in den Süden der Blizzard in den Usa im März
Der war dafür ein perfektes Beispiel ein Wintersturm im März auf den Breitengrad von Süditalien
Absolut verrückt eine Roski, welle Hatte ihn verursacht genauso, wie jetzt klar, wie und dadurch das sei relativ klein?
War ging es auch besonders schnell die Welt Meteorologie Organisation kurz, wm hat alarm geschlagen zitat wir
Bemerkenswerte Veränderungen Rund um den Planeten welche an die Grenzen von unserem Verständnis des Klimawandels geht
Wir sind jetzt auf wirklich unerforschtes Gebiet. Ja, das sagt David Carr cs. Direktor des Weltklima
Forschungsprogramms der wm ja
Also selbst Experten wissen jetzt nicht mehr weiter nur eins ist sicher
Nichts ist sicher niemand kann mir sagen wie viele und wie heftig Stürme in Zukunft sein werden
Das bestätigte heute auch der Klimaforscher am Helmholtz-Zentrum für Ozeanforschung in Kiel Mojib Latif ist gebe Zitat
Keine Anhaltspunkte dafür, dass sind Folge des Klimawandels
Solche extreme weiter zunehmen werden. Ja, das sagte er am Freitag im Südwestrundfunk
Achtung die Betonung liegt auf solche denn
Sie werden natürlich diese Stürme durch die Ausreißer der Ostbevern er mal zu uns in den Süden getrieben
Was dann doch für uns eher mehr als weniger Stimme bedeutet und durch den Temperaturanstieg in Deutschland der Laut Latif seit
1881 bei 1,4 Grad liegt
Da kann die Luft Dank mehr Wasser aufnehmen es regnet dadurch Stärker bei solchen Wetterlagen zudem hält er mehr
Extremwetter
Grundsätzlich für wahrscheinlich Zitat wir erwarten
Dass in Zukunft Wetter extreme häufiger werden zitat ende es wird also ziemlich spannend
Was das Wetter betrifft hier bei Pixum halte ich euch natürlich auf dem Laufenden
Wenn er kein Video zum Thema und auch zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann durch mir hier
ein Abo aufs Auge und vergesst nicht den
Auf die Glocke hier, also hier geht es weiter mit Klimawandel weltweites Wetterchaos hat begonnen? Ja, da gibt es noch mehr
Hintergrundinfos zum Thema sehr spannendes Thema übrigens, also auf keinen Fall verpassen und drauf legen und ansonsten. Bis dann
Bleibt dran